[Musique]
le fait qu'on a diminué le nombre le
nombre de
ah parce qu'on a fait
ces dernières semaines à partir du début
du mois de mai où devraient
progressivement réussir tu vois tout
doucement rire des choses
en visite ce matin dans une école de
melun en seine-et-marne emmanuel macron
a précisé le calendrier de réouverture
mi-mai pour les terrasses et les lieux
culturels avec des jauges limitées et
peut-être un couvre-feu décalé à 20h des
parisiens venus profiter de ce dimanche
ensoleillé mais les gestes barrière eux
sont oubliés c'est des images qui sont
pas admissibles
et moi je comprends que des français qui
font des efforts depuis des mois tous
les jours qui respecte toutes les règles
soient en colère devant ces images là
très honnêtement je préfère voir ça
comme scène que des fêtes qui
s'organisait dans les appartements où on
sait que ça peut ça peut déclencher les
clusters ya les nouvelles études
scientifiques qui montrent que les
contaminations extérieures sont
quasiment impossibles parce que la
transmission et par voie aéroportée la
base dominer comme j'ai dit finie la
date dans les prochains jours
quelques semaines pour ouvrir les
établissements le meurtre de stephany
vendredi dernier et la troisième attaque
terroriste en cinq ans dans le
département
ciblé parce qu'elle travaillait dans un
commissariat cette femme de 49 ans a
reçu l'hommage national de la police
partout en france des militaires dans
une tribune publiée par valeurs
actuelles les militaires dénoncent
ouvrez les guillemets l'islamisme et les
hordes de banlieue il évoque ouvrez les
guillemets le délitement qui frappe
notre patrie on ouvre à nouveau les
guillemets il n'est plus temps de
tergiverser si l'on demande la guerre
civile mettra un terme à ce chaos une
vingtaine pardon de militaires en
retraite qui n'ont rien dit d'autre que
ce que dit d'ailleurs monsieur de
villiers le général de vider lorsqu'il a
quitté l'élysée quelques mois après
l'élection d' emmanuel macron y at-il
aujourd'hui la paix civile est elle
aujourd'hui menacée dans un certain
nombre de quartiers oui tout cas je
condamne sans réserve cette tribune d'un
quarteron de généraux en charentaises
qui appellent au soulèvement 60 ans jour
pour jour après le putsch des généraux
contre le général de gaulle tout cela
n'est pas gratuit
vous voyez le 21 avril le quarteron tout
ça faut arrêter tout ce genre de choses
je veux dire faux faux faux regarde pas
de références historiques standon
charentaise bah écoutez je regarde ce
que j'ai au pied c'est pas tout à fait
ça mais après tout ça me gêne pas c'est
vrai que je suis devenu un vieux con par
rapport à d'autres mais je vais vous
dire j'ai encore assez de peps pour dire
un certain nombre de choses que des
militaires à la retraite parle de hordes
parle de banlieue qui seraient des
banlieues ou au fonds se préparent les
attentats terroristes je dis que c'est
effectivement irresponsable mais c'est
la réalité
voilà c'est tout et si c'est à cause des
attentats terroristes
excusez moi c'est pas à la campagne
encore une fois je vous dis que c'est un
fait que des auteurs d'actes terroristes
dans notre pays on l'a vu à remblai on
l'a vu à conflans sainte honorine
on l'a vu à nice aussi sont le fait de
personnes immigrées maintenant encore
une fois je vous dis moi je n'accepterai
jamais de rentrer dans les discours qui
consiste à dire que terrorisme égale
immigration et inversement alors quoi
vous avez été inspiré par la nouvelle
idée
de marlène schiappa la ministre qui
suggère que le débat d'entre deux tours
la présidentielle 2022 soit animé par
cyril hanouna
oui parce qu'en général quand on fait la
queue qu'on arrive devant un poste
frontière et que le flic nous demandent
nos papillons répond moi c'est peu non
là j'ai pas envie je vous donne pas mon
passeport
mais oui ma petite beauté c'est la
spécialité de marlène schiappa
propositions sorties du chapeau la
petite phrase qui suscite un tollé sur
les réseaux cette fois c'est donc l'idée
de voir l'animateur ne touche pas à mon
poste
arbitre et le débat en 2022